let me ask you about St Louis because my
experience I don't know if you've been
on any of these trips Sona this may have
been before your time but there were a
bunch of times where I had to go as part
of an affiliate trip to different cities
and I think three different times I went
to St Louis and every time I said well I
want to see St Louis and they would say
walk down to the arch and I would walk
down to the arch and kind of look around
and say you got it was there something
part of St Louis that people aren't
showing me yes what were they trying to
hide from me because I kept saying I
want to explore and they always sent me
in the same direction every time so cool
but it is limited it's very cool but
there's a park yes and there's a plaque
that says Jon Hamm sat here and that's
that's it and um you know you get to sit
where Jon Hamm sat and it feels very
John hammy and then uh you move on but
other than that I thought why did really
keep directing me down to this it's a
nice spot yeah
um there's other places too we've got a
nice a Park Forest Park it's bigger than
Central Park
um that's really nice we've got a cool
Children's Museum that people go to as a
destination called the city museum
there's cool places but it's it's spread
out they're little pockets everywhere so
I think that yeah I think they just
wanted to keep you just down by that
Arch just yeah because it is a cool
structure and it isn't people think like
oh can you drive through it like it's a
redwood tree but no it's it's gigantic
you can you can't drive through it you
walk under it but it's it's huge you can
go up in it there's no elevator or
something that's a small elevator that
it has to it shifts as you go so that
you're not turning sideways as it goes
so it shifts it feels very rickety it's
from the 60s I believe and then you get
up there and it kind of sways nothing
nothing built in the 60s uh is safe and
including myself
that was just a bad era whenever someone
said no you're fine it was built in the
60s just don't get on it did you hear
you've been recalled I've been recalled
many times yeah I've been recalled over
and over and over again but no that is
uh yeah wait I gotta ask you about this
affiliate thing because I I heard you
talk about this when you were breaking
down like the history of of late night
and how it came to be you go on these
you go to town to town to talk to
Affiliates to get them to put your show
on uh to make nice with them and it's
it's something why okay this is me as an
Old Timer telling you how things used to
be sure which is when you got a big TV
show or any show you needed to go to
parties where the affiliate people from
the affiliate heads would would come
together and it was like a convention
for them and they wanted to see the
stars yeah and I mean they wanted to see
the friends they wanted to see before
the friends they wanted to see the
people from Wings they wanted to see the
people from Frasier anyone who was on
NBC they wanted to see them and I
couldn't chart the history of network TV
starting from when I got into it in D3
and these parties were massive I mean
giant ice sculptures of a NBC Peacock
and drinks named after all the different
shows and goodie bags and massive stars
at the time like Kelsey Grammer and you
know at the time Bill Cosby uh people
were there and he had his own drinks he
was handing out
let's go clean that up um
yeah I had so many of those
um
uh and then I'd wake up dressed as Lord
Fauntleroy this isn't my outfit
they have these mouth
word to God by the time
um they you know in by the time I'm
getting out of it it was Cash bar you
know we tried to get a puppet for this
event but Alf said no you know it it
really was sort of lead back to album
yeah 20 years out of doing this show and
he still wouldn't do it and he's an
inanimate puppet they just didn't even
want the guy who worked out they just
wanted Alf and Alf said now
but it was just an it was a so I saw the
whole thing but I was still part of that
time when you had to go and talk to
Affiliates and I remembered as late as
2009 going to Oklahoma City and they had
me get on a horse and like ride it
around the I mean you felt like you were
running for a national office and would
they not air your show no part of the
lineup if you don't know no no they
would but it was a way to you know be a
team player okay uh you know in
retrospect it seems insane because now
we live in this different world where
they're streaming and you know no one's
going town to town hey folks let me tell
you about the Conan show gather around
gather around bring the kids now let me
tell you something any questions here
yes will it be on the television yes it
will Clem it will where's Elle
I couldn't be here but he's inanimate I
know it's just a [ __ ] putty I know
do you have any puppets we've no we
don't but it was just a different time
so that's what you did yeah this is so
funny now that it would never occur to
me that that and it's and when I talk to
younger people about the old days of
Television it's just so strange they act
like I'm a fossil but that's what it was
like do you do you miss that time or is
there things about it that you're like
oh I'm so glad that kind of stuff is
over I'm I'm happy that it was so much
extra work that no one ever saw you know
um there was all of this work
uh and chasing around and talking to
people I mean I did it before and the I
mean I did it in 93 uh I did it a couple
times
um throughout those years I used to have
to call Affiliates and check in with
them and you know but I was always on
the verge in the early years of getting
canceled and they were so you would do
anything they said they would say call
these people and I would get on the
phone and go hi I'm doing we're my best
on the show
it's not performing that well and Arma I
know I know uh but it was yeah those
were those were Grim times but I'm glad
that uh that that's done and I think it
seems exhausting on top of doing a
nightly show yeah there was a sick part
of me that kind of liked it I'm kind of
I have a political side and that I like
to work a crowd yeah yeah and um I like
to press the Flash and I like to I
almost take it as a challenge so
sometimes they turn me loose on a room
and I would just go through the whole
room and I just didn't I I there's part
of me that liked it but
ultimately it was energy that you were
expending that wasn't going into the
creative product and that
um that was ultimately I think not not
terrific